[Music]
Giorgio's Dow or Boy George as Boy
George yes of course he's had his own
share of struggles yes he has and
fergenson caught up with a 57 year old
while on tour with his van Culture Club
and the b-52 George revealing how
different being on the road is now and
then you've been very open about your
sobriety how many years now pretend Oh
congratulations congratulations have
each 10 in March this year how is
touring different sober oh my god you
know when I started coach club I was 22
and we went from playing tiny clubs to
playing stadiums like in a flash I would
say that it's taken me a long time to
kind of feel comfortable on stage as the
lead singer of Culture Club Boy George's
Fame has made him as much a target as a
celebrity
I think I'm joyfully cynical I'm not the
person I was when I wrote them so I've
never you know I've never cast myself in
that same role as kind of the victim do
you want to hurt me
they're totally different now yeah I
think in essence or maybe that person's
in there somewhere but you know like
under a lot of makeup at Boy George and
Culture Club are touring with the b-52s
and Fame came just as fast but the
Athens Georgia band they were playing
local gigs until they got a big break on
Saturday Night Live in 1980
[Music]
can you believe it's been 40 years yes
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Pierce have just turned 70 and the
party has never really stopped the music
really came from that from having fun it
came from the heart you're weird and
nuts berries the torte goes into October
culture club plays new songs from an
upcoming album
but there is one artist boy George would
love to work with the weirdest one that
I'm surprised has never happened would
be me a Madonna
[Music]